invité de 5 à 10 au matin rita bonheur
la présidente de l'union des femmes de
la martinique ritter bonheur bonjour les
combats féministes ne consiste pas
seulement à intégrer des sphères du
pouvoir économique et politique mais il
a transformé la société cette citation
d'angela davis est écrite sur votre
carte de voeux pour 2018 pourquoi cette
citation d'abord je souhaite la bonne
année nous souhaitons la bonne année à
toutes les auditrices et tous les
auditeurs de matinée première c'est vrai
que cette année 2010 8,7 une année pour
nous charnière qui est extrêmement
importante parce que ben il ya des
choses qui se sont qui se sont ouvertes
en cette fin d'année 2010 est qu'il faut
continuer il faut il faut rentrer dans
la brèche
il faut profiter de ce changement de ces
interrogations de cette libération de
parole qui se sont déclenchés qui ont
explosé on va dire un en cette fin
d'année 2010 est pour pouvoir continuer
à faire changer les choses à faire
changer les mentalités
alors cette france d'angela davis elle
est tout à fait en phase avec notre mot
d'ordre du dernier congrès qui disait à
l'offensive pour un mieux-être des
femmes dans une société plus juste et
plus solidaire
donc voilà il s'agit pas seulement pour
les femmes de conquérir du pouvoir
d'aller dans les assemblées de dire qu
on est aussi riche ou aussi en vue que
les hommes mais il s'agit véritablement
oui la parité ce n'est qu'un état ce
n'est que oui vous ce n'est qu'un des
aspects on va dire un outil qui permette
aux femmes d'aller plus loin mais on
sait très bien que ce n'est pas ce qui
est
ça n'est pas cela la véritable égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et donc
si nous voulons arriver à 7,7 fin des
discriminations à 7,7 meilleure vie il
faut changer les mentalités en
profondeur mais il faut les changer
aussi parce que on ne peut pas penser
plus d'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes dans un monde inégalités en lui
même les deux sociétés inégalités
transformation de la société qui passe
en martinique par quel type d'action que
vous allez mener en 2018 par exemple
alors on va essayer d'être toujours dans
nos actions de fond puisque c'est ce que
nous faisons de plus en plus voilà il
s'agit pas il s'agit beaucoup de
sensibiliser l'opinion mais il s'agit
aussi d'avoir de plus en plus de relais
de personnes convaincues et pouvant
argumenté et pouvant agir donc à trie
ses acteurs de cette transformation à
travers j'ai envie de dire nos trois
missions 1
c'est vrai l'accueil et l'accompagnement
des femmes victimes de violence puisque
ben c'est quelque chose que nous faisons
et nous sommes les seuls à le faire de
cette façon
donc c'est aussi sensibiliser les femmes
que nous recevons au fait qu'elle ne
vive pas simplement un problème
individuel mais un problème de société à
travers la formation puisque nous avons
désormais un pôle formation prévention
qui non seulement fait des interventions
en établissement scolaire où on essaie
justement de susciter des actions des
jeunes j'ai aussi fait des formations
pour les adultes dans tous les secteurs
de la société justement l'établissement
scolaire ce que est ce que vous adapter
votre discours aux réseaux sociaux aux
jeunes qu'ils sont
dans sur les différents réseaux sociaux
et qui font parfois circuler des vidéos
compromettantes bien entendu on sait que
les réseaux sociaux ont de plus en plus
d'impact sur la vie sur l'éducation et
sur la vision des jeunes et donc bah on
n'est pas là pour leur donner des leçons
comme d'ailleurs dans toutes nos actions
nous nous donnons de leçon à personne
nous sommes là pour écouter pour
travailler ensemble pour enrichir ce
post enrichir mutuellement de des idées
d une des uns et des autres et d'avancer
ensemble
donc il s'agit à partir de ce qui existe
de partir de cela et de discuter pour
faire évoluer les mentalités et c'est
aussi ce que nous allons faire à travers
nos actions aux langes de
sensibilisation toute l'année dans le
journal le monde d'hier
un collectif de 100 femmes a signé une
tribune pour je cite défendre une
liberté d'importuner d'importuner
indispensable à la liberté sexuelle ces
femmes disent également ne pas se
reconnaître dans un féminisme qui au
delà de la dénonciation des abus du
pouls de pouvoir prend le visage d'une
haine des hommes et de la sexualité
fin de citation vous vous reconnaissez
non mais je trouve que c'est pathétique
enfin on a entendu les réactions très
nombreuses par rapport à cela deux
femmes de féministes et d'hommes
d'ailleurs qui dénonce cela mais j'ai
envie de prendre un à un contrepied je
dirais que nous connaissons bien
tous les esclaves n'ont pas combattu
l'esclavagé
vous savez il y en a qui disent eh ben
on le met très bon et il m'a donné un
petit lopin de terre donc bon pourquoi
est-ce que je vais le combattre c'est
pareil on est dans une société où on
baigne dans une dans une culture
machiste et oui il y à des femmes qui
qui pense que c'est très bien comme ça
qui s'illusionnent sur des marques de
reconnaissance qui n'en sont pas et qui
pensent que bon il faut protéger les
hommes les pauvres qui sont des victimes
donc bon c'est aussi quelque part une
façon j'ai envie de dire de se démarquer
de ce fait on reconnaître de faire
parler de soi donc moi nous nous croyons
que bien sûr elle disait si tu es le
disent aussi que que qu'il y ait une
forme de justice expéditive notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux qui compte la
fin
même statut d'éternelle victime faut-il
faut-il alors c'est pas parce qu'on est
victime qu'on ne peut pas ce qu'on ne se
défend pas un bon c'est simplement un
statut qui aura connu
je veux dire bon quand vous avez une
personne qui est victime de viol ce
n'est pas parce qu'elle dit je suis
victime de viol que ben elle va rester
toute sa vie sans rien faire pareil pour
les victimes de violences donc
reconnaître un statut de victime à
quelqu'un ne signifie pas l'enfermer
dans ce statut et en faire une personne
faible se montrer dangereux c'est un
discours j'ai envie de dire enfin je dis
c'est pathétique enfin je pense que ça
sera un épiphénomène très franchement au
regard des milliers et des centaines de
milliers de femmes jeunes qui qui on
parlait justement qui ont révélé leurs
souffrances qu'ils ont montré
l'importance extrême de cette de ce
harcèlement qui est quotidien pour les
femmes quel que soit l'endroit où elle
se trouve et ce n'est pas les victimiser
que de le dire quand vous avez des
personnes connues des actrices des
artistes serra qui vous parle de ce
qu'elles ont vécu
eh bien elle ce n'est que la face
émergée d'un iceberg de toutes les
femmes au quotidien de ce qu'elles
vivent donc c'est reconnaître cela c'est
justement le prendre en compte pour se
dire mais qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ce
n'est pas possible de continuer comme ça
il faut que à la fois les femmes mais
aussi les hommes prennent conscience que
les choses doivent changer
et c'est vrai que beaucoup d'hommes sont
aussi dans cette dynamique de duke il se
retrouve enfermé dans des stéréotypes et
dans des images dans lesquelles eux
mêmes ne se reconnaissent pas et qu'ils
ont envie de faire éclater alors lors de
la journée de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes
le président de la république manuel
macron a annoncé la création d'un délit
d' outrage sexistes punissant le
harcèlement du ru donc fini les petites
dans l'est dans les rues si ça est-ce
que ça fait plaisir aux femmes vraiment
le psy dans la rue luczak si ce n'est
pas seulement ça pour commencer
d'ailleurs bon moi je vais vous dire on
a eu dernièrement
une débat là dessus et les hommes qui
étaient présents puisque ce débat était
mixte et ce que nous souhaitons les
hommes qui étaient présents nous ont dit
mais je ne me rendais pas compte de cela
une femme oui on peut considérer que
c'est une marque d'honneur de faire un
petit dans la rue à une femme mais quand
vous avez une femme qui traverse
plusieurs rues et qui a une fois deux
fois trois fois cette fois dix fois
l'aube site les remarques sexistes les
gestes voire même bong et être touchés
vous pouvez vous dire que oui on peut
considérer que c'est du harcèlement
donc nous ne pouvons pas je veux dire
que ce n'est pas un acte isolé
malheureusement et c'est quelque chose
que les femmes subissent jour après jour
et de façon continue
donc il faut le voir oui comme un
harcèlement comme quelque chose qui
n'est pas normal
et comme une pression et comme une
souffrance des femmes alors comment
pouvait justement et mettre en place les
sanctions parce que tout cela
alors c'est vrai que ce délit bon moi
j'ai envie de dire que pour nous c'est
plus une annonce alors sur le principe
c'est à dire que c'est un affichage de
condamnation de ces actes et zap aux
yeux non je ne dirais pas comme ça je
dis que c'est un affichage de
condamnation de l'acte et qui peut faire
réfléchir les gens les hommes qui
s'adonnent à ce genre d'acte maintenant
et qui peut rendre plus forte aussi les
femmes en se disant bon on peut être
protégé maintenant c'est vrai que dans
la réalité 2
voilà deux de ce qui peut se passer
pouvoir est faire intervenir la police
pour pouvoir dresser mon ce set cette
sanction cette infraction
ça va être effectivement très difficile
autre sujet qui fait débat c'est l'âge
du consentement sexuel des mineurs pour
le président macron il doit être fixée
at je dois être fixés à cette limite
doit être fixée à 15 ans d'autres
étaient en faveur de se fixer à 13 ans
vous vous en pensez quoi
déjà nous pensons qu'il est impensable
qu'on dise à une jeune fille de 11 ans
qu'elle était consentante parce que elle
a été violée par un jeune parent un
garçon enfin par quelqu'un de plus âgé
et de lui dire que non non elle était
complètement consentante c'est
impensable c'est sait on ne peut même
pas qualifier cela voilà parce qu'on
sait très bien qu'à onze ans on n'est
pas capable quelquefois de dire non on
n'est pas capable de réagir et on n'est
pas capable d'avoir suffisamment de
maturité pour avoir un choix
complètement mature voilà donc bon nous
on pense que quinze ans c'est très bien
après moi je trouve que 13 ans est
encore un peu juste
donc 15 ans pour nous c'est bon ça fait
partie des des mesures que le président
macron a présenté le 25 novembre
c'est très bien il a présenté des
mesures très intéressante
maintenant le problème c'est de savoir
avec quels moyens on va pouvoir déployer
ces mesures-là très bien alors dernière
question que pensez vous de ce metteur
en scène de florence qui a réécrit la
fin de carmen de bizet dans l'oeuvre
originale carmen est assassiné par don
de josé et dans la version de l'est au
muscat tôt donc si le nom de cette 2e mi
temps notre metteur en scène ces cars
memc assassines dont josé bon nous on
est pourquoi personne n'a sassine
personnes donc elle fut connue chez nous
comme carmen c'est une façon peut-être
d'attirer l'attention c'est une façon
peut-être d'attirer l'attention
et de montrer qu'il ya moyen de faire
autre chose de faire autrement dans la
société donc bon c'est la voix de
l'artiste qui a choisi ce moyen là ben
nous on est tous les jours en tout cas
dans nos actions à faire réfléchir à
analyser a invité la population à
décrypter notre société pour pouvoir la
faire avancer
pour un mieux être des femmes et des
hommes rita bonheur je vous remercie
excellente journée à l'écouté de nos
programmes merci à vous
[Musique]